apple's wwdc event is coming up in just
a few days and there is a ton of
speculation going on
surrounding what apple is going to be
announcing including both software and
hardware
so what i'm going to do in this video is
go through some recently revealed leaks
rumors and hints from apple themselves
to figure out what we should
realistically
expect and what we shouldn't so let's
get right into it
first off dub dub dc has always been
apple's software developer event
where they always reveal the next
versions of their software
for each of their products so we're
going to be seeing everything from ios
15 and ipad os 15
to watch os 8 and even mac os monterey
which apparently might be the name of
the next mac os update
based on recent leaks and rumors so
before i get into the very juicy details
about the hardware we should be
expecting
i want to talk about some new software
features first
mainly for the iphone and the brand new
m1 ipad pro
apple has recently been releasing
teasers of their wwdc event
showcasing a bunch of memojis and other
things as well
so i wanted to kind of dig deep into
what those could potentially be hinting
at
looking at this first image you can see
a lot of emojis of people from different
races and backgrounds
excited about wwdc but you'll also see
some of them
reacting to messages that others have
sent
so they're kind of interacting with each
other and since there are so many of
them
there have been rumors of this hinting
at apple releasing
their new privacy focused social media
network
to compete with facebook and this makes
a lot of sense because apple has
recently been battling facebook
over privacy concerns and many people
have been upset with facebook over those
issues
on top of that the new twitter hash flag
for this year's event is basically a
thumbs up emoji
within an imessage so the new network
would likely be based on that somehow or
some way
so if apple does end up making their own
social media network
i can say for sure that i'm switching
over because i trust apple way more with
my personal info
then i trust facebook and i have a
feeling that it's not only going to be
available on apple devices
but android as well just so there's not
going to be any antitrust issues there
now on top of that if apple is going all
out on this privacy thing
we might even see apple release their
own privacy focused
search engine which has been rumored for
a long time now
and i'm excited about it because i know
nothing is going to be able to track me
across the web and as far as other
features we can expect
connor jewish on twitter posted that we
could be seeing
everything from a new food tracking
feature ui changes
new notification settings and look on
lock screen and
dark mode and messages app tweaks now in
terms of the new mac os
dylan dkt on twitter believes that wwdc
will bring better support for iphone and
ipad apps
on apple silicon max by allowing
developers to more easily bring them to
the mac
without using catalyst and this makes
total sense because the ios app
experience
hasn't been so great so far on the m1
max
and now let's get into the start of the
show and something that many of you have
been wondering and asking about
and that's ipad os 15. as we know the
new m1 ipad pro
is extremely powerful compared to the
previous model and i would honestly say
that it is
overkill for most people because even
the 2018 ipad pro
can run basically every app on the app
store without
any issues at all but with the new m1
ipad pro one problem we noticed was that
in real world
video editing performance we didn't
really see any improvement at all
in fact it was slightly slower than the
previous model
and that's because the software just
isn't utilizing
the performance well enough and then a
bit later
we compared two m1 ipad pros one with
eight gigs of ram and another with
16 and we found that there was literally
no difference at all
even when we tried to max out the ram
and check up on which apps
stayed open and shortly after that we
found out why
as of right now apps within ipad os can
only use up to a maximum of around 5
gigs of ram that is literally a defined
limit within the software and developers
cannot make an app use
more than around 5 gigs even if they
tried so the main
question is why in the world would apple
allow people to spend
so much more cash on a 16 gig ipad pro
if you can't even take advantage of it
well i fully believe that apple is
planning to remove
or at least raise that 5 gig ram limit
for apps within ipad os 15.
and on top of that i fully believe that
apple is planning to release pro apps
like final cut logic and xcode and
here's why
first off john prosser leaked this in a
tweet last year
saying that those apps are 100 coming to
the ipad pro
second the m1 chip in the ipad pro is
identical
to the one in the latest max so all of
the required hardware
is there third if apple doesn't release
those pro apps
there are going to be a ton of people
who will be extremely upset with apple
for basically gimping their expensive
ipad pro and not allowing it to use the
full extent of its performance
which is very clearly overkill for all
of the apps that we already have
and fourth in the case of final cut pro
it would make total sense to have it on
the ipad pro
especially since it recently got support
for hdr video editing
and the new 12.9 inch model has the new
mini led display
which is perfect for that and of course
beyond that there's gonna be some other
improvements as well
like most likely having full external
display support
and probably some new augmented reality
features or updates for the lidar
scanner
and with all of that software stuff out
of the way let's get into what you guys
are really here for
the hardware starting with the
redesigned macbook pros
over a month ago i tweeted that i am
officially claiming that apple's
redesigned m1x macbook pros
will be announced at wwdc and in my
explanation video
i showed how all of the leaks and rumors
came together for me to make that
announcement
so let me give you guys my main four
reasons for why i initially thought that
it would happen
first a lot of the rumors at the time
were pointing to a release date in the
second half of 2021
which begins in july second since apple
revealed
the new imac and ipad pro at their
spring loaded event
but only started shipping them an entire
month later
i figured that apple could do the same
thing with the macbook pro
reveal at wwdc and ship in july
third it was reported that apple had
already begun production of the m1x chip
and based on the timeline of when apple
began the production of the m1 chip last
year
and the time that it actually was
revealed it made total sense for the m1x
chip
to be ready for shipment in july and
fourth everyone agrees that apple
absolutely must show off these new
macbook pros at an event
since they're getting fully redesigned
so it wouldn't make sense for
apple to wait until the next october or
november event
to reveal the new macbook pros if the
chips are basically already
ready to go for a july launch and ever
since i made that video there have been
more and more people
believing that we're getting new macbook
pros at wwdc
including john prosser who confirms that
a macbook pro is coming
maguire wood who also says it's coming
at wwdc
luke miyani who says he is going to
start in only fans if they don't come at
wwc
and even the very reliable leaker mark
german who says that the redesigned
macbook pros are expected to debut
as soon as early this summer saying that
both the 14 and 16 inch models
will be launched at the same time and on
top of all of that
apple released some more teaser images
of memojis
in front of macbooks and if you zoom
into the reflection in the glasses
you'll see three code words for eat
sleep
macbook possibly hinting at a new
macbook coming at wwdc
so based on all of that information i
still fully believe that the redesigned
macbook pros
are going to be revealed at wwdc and yes
my goatee is still on the line in case
we don't see them
in just a few days and just in case you
guys are wondering what features and
specs i'm personally expecting for the
14
and 16 inch macbook pros here's a full
screenshot
with all the specs that i think are
going to be coming and with that said
i believe that there is a good chance
that the m1x mac mini
could also be coming alongside the
macbook pros at wwc
and here's why first off when apple
revealed the m1 chip in november
they gave it to both the macbooks and
the mac mini
at the same time so i can see them
repeating that method
with the new m1x chip as well second the
m1x macbook pros
will be directly replacing the high-end
intel
13-inch macbook pro and the 16-inch
macbook pro
which are still currently up for sale on
apple's website and if you didn't
already know
the intel based mac mini is still also
up for sale
for 10.99 so it would totally make sense
for apple to do it all in one sweep
instead of waiting longer for the mini
and third john prosser was able to get
his hands on some images or cad files
of the redesigned m1x mac mini and so
far
it looks pretty believable and matches
up to what anyone would expect
for the redesign so if they were able to
get their hands on the leaks
this early it could mean that the new
mini is ready to be revealed
at wwdc so with all that said let's
finish off with some things that you
should not expect
at this year's wdc you probably
shouldn't expect the 30 inch m1x imac
or the m2 macbook air you shouldn't
expect the new air pods and you
shouldn't expect
any other ipads either just the new
macbook pros and potentially the mac
mini now if you totally disagree with my
speculations in this video
go ahead and comment your thoughts down
below but if you enjoyed it
click that circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one definitely
check out one of those two right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video